[Music]
after christmas georgie and i talked
about what his ex-wife octavia said
about her thinking they weren't divorced
and
you know this american trash comment
about us and him saying you know when
the money's gone
i'm gone you know and georgia told me he
never said that
okay come on little squats
hey hold on let me get on
oh
how about this help of the world
yeah
i just had to believe that georgie was
telling the truth i just have to let
that go for now if i want to continue
this relationship
don't drop him don't drop me
you gotta catch me you got me
i like to
work hard yeah we should make it a to be
outside every day
couple routine yeah i'm i'm down for
that
don't forget about dinner tonight with
debbie marina
and stacy florence so i think we can
maybe all hash it out
there's nothing to hash outs
i plan this dinner tonight with everyone
to discuss what happened and to see how
we can move forward debbie and brenda
and stacy do have concerns about georgie
you know they're still upset that
georgie called us american trash
i don't like that tension in the air
between
me my friends my fiance
just hope everything goes well
georgie i just want everything to be
worked out i want everyone to hash out
i'm about to go to turkey i want to go
there with a peaceful mindset knowing
that everything's going to be okay why
need to worry about this
you need to worry about the more serious
stuff you could
for your going turkey your recovery yeah
[Music]